نشر الرائد والفضاء الاماراتي سلطان
النيادي مقطع فيديو مدهشا من محطه الفضاء
الدوليه يشرح فيه كيف يتشكل الماء في
الفضاء لنشاهد
[موسيقى]
ضجه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بصور
للملياردير الشهير ايلون ماسك وهو يرقص مع
الروبوت كاتينيلا فيما اعتبره رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي انه اعلان عن زوجته
المستقبليه التي صنعها وصممها بمواصفات
الانثى التي يحلم بها الروبوت مزود بوسائل
حسيه تجعله يشعر بالحزن والسعاده ودعت
عقليه متزنه وبالبحث عن حقيقه الصور تبين
ان الموضوع مزيف وصور ماسك المتداوله صممت
بواسطه بواسطه تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي اي
اي
مقطع فيديو متداول عالميا يظهر لقطات
مثيره لجندي روسي وحيدا يتوسل لطائره
مسيره اوكرانيه لعدم قصفه حيث القت
الطائره على الجندي رساله تحتوي على
تعليمات حول كيفيه تسليم نفسه بدلا من
قصفه بالمتفجرات الجندي الروسي وافق على
شروط الاستسلام وسلم نفسه نتابع
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من انها تكبره بالسته وعشرين
عاما لم يمنع فارق العمر معلمه ان تتزوج
من تلميذها في ماليزيا تزوج شاب يبلغ من
العمر 22 عاما من معلمته السابقه التي
تبلغ من العمر 48 عاما الزواج اثار جدلا
واسعا بعدما انتشر صور حفل الزفاف على
مواقع التواصل
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات